hey guys how's it going it's Justine and
this is my sister Jenna oh happy Easter
these ears were compliments of Jenna she
brought them out she's like is this an
Easter video it wasn't really soft yes
it is they are very soft after this I
think the dog wants them he keeps trying
to get them off of our head he was
really into him he is so today we were
playing this game I went on Amazon I
searched for Easter game puts showed up
that must have taken you all day so
funny so this game is called jumping
jack and you basically well the little
bit of research that I did you pull
carrots out of the ground and then you
have to catch the rabbit to whoever
catches the rabbit when he jumps out of
the ground wins this is gonna be super
competitive I'm in great let's open it
up
tell me jack tell me done something Jess
what are the ages on here probably to
avoid lower no that's how many people
can play it
Oh four plus choking hazard do not put
the pieces in your own don't tell me
what to do lady
oh here's Jack oh my goodness I'm sorry
he's on the Box he was swinging out all
right okay squishy okay cuz he like
jumps out of here you don't want to get
hurt you have to catch him in a basket
okay doesn't actually change anything
since I didn't know
the first step is to plant the carrots
in the bunny hill on it by pushing one
carrot into each bowl until you hear a
click
rack of carrot pushes through these fly
out know the basket to pick which color
you want
I'd like the purple it matches my ears
my legs but then like there's no
contrast true you do what you want so
number two we place Jack on his bunny
hill by pushing him into the post in the
center of the hill oh we gotta Jam him
in here should we wear safety glasses no
that's why he's soft he's not that soft
he saw he's like medium
don't touch Jack he's busy right now
put the spinner where all players can
reach it okay well here we go so you
spin the wheel so each player is
removing however many carats is on here
the endless players so freaking of
always the youngest player stars for
first
do you need an adult to read I'm just
saying it's pretty catch Jack in basket
do here might want a carrot in the back
can we put the carrots in the bass why
would we catch him in the basket I'm not
sure yeah you put it in your basket
okay let's youngest player goes first I
don't know what these things in it
what's the X mean that no you don't get
to pick a carrot okay you pick two
carrots he's like two carrots you spun
the wheel put your hand on the table
lady that's me the winner let's play
again my turn tally it up one zero
but it's on the line epic three no yeah
so what's the stupid basketful where you
put your carrots okay two carrots ready
one Clara this is really just two
carrots
what's that mean that means you don't
get it you know nothing is use I
supposed to take one of your carrots
then why wouldn't I want to go because I
would want to be able to catch him I'm
super confused it's for four-year-olds
[Music]
how are you know it's a thief okay
anyway let's go you're so fast it's fine
a better at driving reflexes okay to
zero how is this happening all right
well I'm going again cuz I'm a loser
when are you guys blocking jack parents
to remind you not to lean over jack is
stupid thanks to Gerrits oh you're
blocking jack - carrots react here oh
all right
can we just practice can you just throw
in the air for me real quick no II oh
okay see I can catch all right
how hmm I mean you knew it was coming
that's why you're winning
he's cracking your piece-of-crap this
game is really I hope you didn't spend
too much money on it
- carrots
I will say I'm actually enjoying this a
lot should be a great party game Oh
guess what
that's my carrot now why because there
was a thief in the night
sure false start
yes Ernie I love your little basket my
basket is so full
jam it in there I'm super confused what
does that mean that means there was a
thief and they came and ate your carrot
I've got no care what am I doing wrong
Oh my basket but wait do I win because I
have a lot of carrots
drop the jack look at Jack's Tom he's
like okay we'll use again I'm getting
very mad I'm getting very mad this is a
children's game and I can't even catch a
freaking radical man with a stupid hole
jamming there's a jam even after you
have all the things okay I'm gonna play
like Antoine my back no you won carrot I
had so many carrots I should've won your
spin this high action game Oh give me
that this spinner is trash you're really
all I did your wire I can like sense it
I'm so amped up that's one I'm like
twitching man like nightmares but okay
next okay and I spun it yeah so I take
one of yours you dummy
okay well you can't catch them a rabbit
for a child you the spinner it's going
the wrong way
you can't just spend Anthony like me
help okay but it's all spinning you put
those yeah put those pointers down put
your pointer down show anyone so like is
she's not moving my reflexes aren't
actually it doesn't make sense it
doesn't make sense to me why I can't
freaking catch the stupid okay let's
just try we just we just don't wanna
play by yourself yeah good let's jam all
these carrots in there and I just want
you to take them out and I wanna be able
to catch this one just let me touch this
one is it competitive no this is just
this is like this is one of those things
where like your child is like really not
good and you trying to like make them
feel better okay we're ready
maybe you do it you pull so you take
them out and I just need to be ready
we should time it put your hands on the
counter oh it doesn't even matter okay
what do you do now we're gonna compete
who can catch him this is so fun here
it's okay just to be fair all right you
have to put the character sighs caffeine
come on amped up like super ready catch
Jack my turn I'm gonna catch him are we
competing like I am repetitively loser
so here's the thing I win all the DIY
challenges this is where I shine this is
looking so Wow well I think you're
scared that's the part you're like sure
that's the problem
well this is actually pretty fun usually
I sometimes whenever I play these games
I'll end up just like donating these but
I'm going to keep this one because this
is fun party parties with the ones
definitely my adult friends oh I can't
beat them too well thank you guys so
much for watching happy Easter if you
guys have any other suggestions for some
fun games similar to this or maybe you
know even a little bit more adult is
fine with me
clearly that's not actually we need low
level more brightness infant games this
is incredible I don't this is this is so
so dumb I'm so upset right now even
Maddie's upset I think my favorite a
cute oh you know you're supposed to get
rid of that I thought you were like how
many guys are in the basket I'll put the
carrot in first that's hard okay I'm
gonna go and see what the dogs are
barking about they say oh here is my
next video bye you have to put the
carrots in first right don't I'm so
upset about this game yeah
[Music]